this morning millions of americans are
hitting the road to get a jump start on
their fourth of july weekend according
to
aaa more than 47 million people are
expected on the roads
and in the sky nearly matching
pre-pandemic
levels errol barnett shows us what's in
store for travelers errol good morning
hey there good morning eureka you and
everyone else hitting the roads can
expect
lots of company this increased demand in
fuel is really
pushing prices up at this fuel station
here in washington dc
it's an exxon prices moved up a few
cents to three dollars
29 cents this morning that's slightly
higher than the national average
which is three dollars 13 cents a gallon
right now
all of this about a 42 percent jump from
where we were
just this time last year and we should
highlight that if you see while you're
out on the roads
fuel stations that are out of gas please
do not freak out
there is no fuel shortage it's just that
many fuel
drivers that were laid off during the
pandemic have not returned to work so in
some places around the country
uh gas stations are having a hard time
getting fuel to the pump
but don't worry it is there and it's
another sign of traveler
optimism when we look at how many people
are flying three and a half million
expected to take to the skies over this
pandemic weekend and if you're not near
the television
can you guess the top fourth of july
destinations this weekend they're on
your screen now according to
aaa that is vegas mile high denver
anaheim in california
and orlando and the cardinal rule for
any road trip tony the driver gets to
pick the music
so follow that and you'll keep the peace
out there as you head to your favorite
spots
this fourth of july weekend errol with
the news and the travel tips thank you
very much we appreciate it